e
la sécurité des usagers du côté
de la Colombie-Britannique et
celle du Grand Montréal.
- Nous sommes à bord
de la voiture patrouille
des agentes Amanda Steed
et Sandra Garofalo.
Elles font partie de la Police
du transport du Grand Vancouver,
une organisation créée
dans l'unique but d'assurer
ité des usagers du
SkyTrain, et cela jour et nuit.
- So, donc à Main Station,
c'est... il y a potentiellement
quelqu'un de suicidaire.
- L'individu a été repéré
par les préposés du centre de
surveillance vidéo du Skytrain.
De leur position, ils peuvent
guider les deux policières sur
le terrain. Le succès de leur
intervention d'urgence dépend de
la rapidité avec laquelle elles
atteindront les lieux, surtout
l est question de sauver
une vie sur une infrastructure
électrifiée en mouvement.
SANDRA GAROFALO, agente, Police
du transport du Grand Vancouver
- Sur la plateforme,
un homme qui était au niveau
de l'ascenseur et qui, en fait,
se penchait dangereusement
vis-à-vis des rails.
Donc c'est possible...
possiblement un jumper,
donc on a peut-être quelqu'un
de suicidaire qui est...
qui va sauter sur sur les rails.
- En 2021, la Police
du transport de Vancouver a dû
intervenir pour deir pour deir s
d'appels d'urgence en raison
d'incivilités et d'infractions
au Code criminel.
Depuis la première pelletée
de terre du REM, les services de
police impliqués dans le projet
redoutent que cette réalité
se transporte dans le Grand
. On estime déjà que
ce nouveau métro aérien pourrait
accueillir jusqu'à 150 000
passagers à chaque jour
lors de la première année
d'entrée en servic
Visiblement insatisfaites
qu'un plan d'intervention ait
été conçr implication,
sept directions de police
ont jugé bon d'interpeller
CDPQ Infra et ses partenaires
en décembre 2020.
On demande à Jean-Marc Arbaud,
infrastructures de la Caisse
de dépôt, de prendre
plus au sérieux la sécuritédes .
La police a perdu patience
de ne pas avoir d'interlocuteurs
ayant un statut décisionnel pour
se pencher sur les
urgents de sécurité du public.
JEAN-VINCENT LACROIX, directeur
des communications, CDPQ Infra
- Les échanges aujourd'hui sont
en place, le dialogue est amorcé
et ça se fait de façon très,
très bonne de part et d'autre.
st pourtant qu'à la fin
du printemps dernier, soit
plus d'un an et demi après
le cri d'alarme des services
de police, que le processus
former une équipe d'inspecteurs
a été lancé.
- Les équipes de sûreté,
elles vont avoir un bon nombre
de pouvoirs liés au règlement
du REM.
- Mais face à la criminalité
déjà connue dans le métro de
Montréal, ce consultant doute
de la capacité des inspecteurs
à répondre à la tâche.
MARIO BERNIQUÉ, ancien resp.
formation mesures d'urgence, SQ
- Il faut suivre à partir de ça,
c'est pour ça que ça va prendre
à quelque part autre que
des constables spéciaux puis
des inspecteurs. Ça va prendre
un service de police ou
un service spécial pour voir
comment ça se déplace toute
cette bonne criminalité-là.
- À trois mois de l'entrée
en service de l'antenne Rive-Sud
du REM, CDPQ Infra n'a pas
de projection en matière
de criminalité.
- Je dirais qu'à ce niveau-là,
c'est vraiment les services
policiers, les services
d'incendie. Mais ces réseaux-là
sont évidemment établis dans
des municipalités, des secteurs,
d'où la collaboration qui est
importante de part et d'autre.
Et c'est un élément clé
sur lequel on travaille et
c'est en cours présentement.
- Dans un contexte de pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre, le recrutement
aurait dû débuter bien avant
le printemps, compte tenu
de l'entrée en service prévue
dans quatre mois.
- Au moment qu'il y a
une pénurie d'emplois, ça touche
tout le monde. Dépendamment
les offres qu'il va y avoir
et puis les conditions,
ça ne sera pas évident
de trouver du personnel
à l'intérieur de tout ça,
surtout si c'est du 24/7.
- Une chose est certaine,
les constables spéciaux
de la STM et les policiers
de la section métro du SPVM
n'ont pas chômé depuis le début
de l'année.
Dans les six premiers mois
de 2022, ils ont dû intervenir
pour près de 1000 infractions au
Code criminel dans les stations
du métro de Montréal.
À Vancouver, TransLink,
le propriétaire du SkyTrain,
n'a pas eu à se faire tirer
l'oreille pour renforcer
la sécurité de ses usagers.
C'est lui-même en 2004 qui a
fait les démarches nécessaires
pour que son agence
de constables spéciaux devienne
l'année suivante un corps
policier en bonne et due forme.
Le chef affirme que
ce changement est venu soulager
les 22 municipalités desservies
par le SkyTrain, où différents
services de police ont
juridiction.
En 2021, ils ont répondu
à plusieurs appels pour
des infractions au Code criminel
qui auraient largement dépassé
les pouvoirs d'un constable
spécial. Nous avons visité
le quartier général de la Police
du transport du Grand Vancouver.
Depuis que l'équipe de
constables spéciaux a été abolie
il y a 17 ans, le budget du
service de police a été augmenté
pour favoriser l'embauche.
Aujourd'hui, la Police du
transport regroupe 200 agents,
une centrale d'urgence 911,
une section des enquêtes et,
depuis les Jeux olympiques
de Vancouver en 2010,
une escouade canine.
Le sergent responsable
de l'unité rappelle que
les infrastructures liées
au transport collectif sont
les premières cibles pour
des attentats terroristes.
Avec la situation mondiale
actuelle, le sergent affirme que
le Canada n'a pas que des alliés
à travers le monde.
Il explique que beaucoup de
colis sont fréquemment vérifiés
par l'escouade canine, entraînée
pour détecter la poudre
explosive.
Pour l'agente Sandra Garofalo,
qui a vécu à Montréal avant de
joindre les rangs de la Police
du transport, les appréhensions
des services de police
du Grand Montréal sont fondées.
- Je pense que la criminalité
à Montréal est identique
à celle de Vancouver parce qu'on
a des personnes armées partout.
- Elle ne croit pas qu'un civil,
malgré son statut d'inspecteur,
pourra intervenir lors de
la commission d'un crime
dans le REM.
- Si par exemple il y a
une agression en cours,
la personne aujourd'hui, nous,
nos préposés aux trains ne
doivent en aucun cas intervenir
puisqu'ils n'ont pas
la formation que les policiers
reçoivent, l'utilisation
de la force.
- Si tout se passe comme prévu,
le premier tronçon de l'antenne
Rive-Sud du REM devrait entrer
en fonction le 1er décembre
prochain